all right Gilbert Gilbert where'd you
grow up are you from I'm from ball
Heights East LA area he's doing and tell
me about your family
oh I got a my mom my dad still in the
picture
although they'd never been really
supportive of my how can I save my life
you know the way I live to to affero
drugs and gangs and just living in the
street they're there but there's like
sounds like they're not there you know
emotionally and supportive they're just
there what age were you when you joined
a gang I was 15 years old when I join a
gang my first gang the reason I joined
was to feel like I belong to something
you know my parents were never really
there they always worked you know I'll
go to school come back home they weren't
there you know no no no love no
affection no nothing they bought me toys
but you know to this day it might even
my dad saw me one time like you know you
always had everything you want it grew
away while you growing up all you needed
was love you know my dad was an abusive
father used to beat up my mom you know I
started seeing them Peter my mom when I
was five years old in front of me she
was obviously cruised to up in a routine
and to this day my mom is in denial you
know she says that oh it never happened
and there happened but I've seen it all
you know my dad was a crackhead he lost
two properties you know while I was
growing up we own two houses and he
ended up losing him because the people
that moved in they were paying him with
crack so you know he eventually he lost
those houses you know and but to this
day I love my dad you know he's my hero
used to be my hero I looked up to him
because he was a type of [ __ ]
that who go to work you go to work and
I'm here he always used to carry a gun
here used to like drinking by myself so
when I was growing up I'll see him
bumping music with the trunk open
Spanish music had his cowboy hat on and
he always killed his pistol you know so
I would look outside the window and I
would like admire that you know cuz
that's like a tough badass you know but
um
little by little which is sorry as I get
a heist I got older you just started
fading away you know because now I'm
more mature thinking oh whoa used to
pick up my palm used to beat me up for
nothing it used to get cracked out and
just would mean for nothing for free you
know get my ass whoopings for free so
that's the kind of environment I got
brought up I mean you know I ran away I
ran away when I was 13 years old my
husband first time I ran away and got
and choose to listen to my gang junior
high so I started shooting with the guys
you know one thing led to another and
next thing you know I'm part of my hood
you know I got love for my hood because
it always be there regardless you know I
might disappear for a minute or whatnot
but if I need somebody to push comes to
shove if I really need my homies to go
kill somebody they're gonna be right
there and go do it with me you know
pretty much you know I got introduced to
Skid Row in 1986 when it was really tent
city you know I said I did it up to
crack habit I used to smoke crack nice
to go to work and I suspend my whole
paycheck on crack I used to go get the
terminal down the street for two days
and and by Sunday born and check out
time I was there broke and I will go
back to work
with nothing hungry as a [ __ ] no
lunch money no nothing you know so after
that I started living out here in the
streets
I'd steer around town in between 56 I
should sell dope I saw a crystal meth
and heroin and for a good minute I was
doing it real good I was cashing over
$1,000 every day but I learned the hard
way you know the first time I sold crack
and a wrong block you know the blacks
approached me like hey where's my money
at and I like what money and you just
followed my block it took flight I mean
boom boom and I started fighting with
like four more [ __ ] blacks right
there you know I could only do so much
so I started running away they chased me
a pistol fell out luckily the Lord works
in mysterious ways
the police happened to just hit the
corner they flashed everybody running
and they said no they pulled everybody
over the black that I hear was bleeding
and they were late you know what was
going on [ __ ] that [ __ ] job me I don't
know [ __ ] you know anyways they made me
for this way and they they still held
them guys back but I I didn't learn I
didn't go nowhere I was still here you
know like I said I was cashing in over a
thousand dollars every day you know and
I would take care of the whole block you
mean I'll feed everybody every every
[ __ ] body you know saying we're but
down here is ain't no righteousness no
loyalty no nothing because I hate to
take care of these [ __ ] home
people I used to feed to play anybody
they came out with my short money I'll
still bless them hey I need to wake up
I'll bless them you know I looked up for
everybody
people that got out of jail well somehow
me what's your purpose right here or
you're just saying I running my block G
oh well I'm not doing I know where to go
what's yourself on your my tent I'll
give them like I'm a pot of dope you
know saying you know and I just put them
on hey you owe me this and I'm just do
what you got to do and you know and you
know eventually I started building my
own circle my own people my own crowd
etc you know I had every [ __ ] thing
from from women to electronics bikes
furniture I have my [ __ ] hooked up I
mean really hooked up you know but I
came to a point where like I said
there's no loyalty down here no
righteousness one of my own crew members
and without dropping a dime on me you
know as soon as one I want to go read up
I'll be back holy [ __ ] down you already
got what you got
make your money I'll be back and go real
and I'm going to go read up I came back
all right everybody get the [ __ ] out you
know say let me go stash my [ __ ] and
when I stashed my [ __ ] next thing you
know you just hear the engine room the
narcs soaping up and you know a which
the dope and was a dope I don't know
what you guys talking about
and then it came out on the radio I
think all 10-4 we were just important
that he went in for real you know real
is a certain word that we use I hear
that's the slang you know and now yeah
so this is one lazy [ __ ] ended
up snitching on me
when I took care of them and I did I
would do anything for these people you
know or at least from a crowd where it
shows me is our loyalty you know you
know I've seen I seen females getting
raped out here you know say man you can
do share the body because it doesn't it
doesn't pertain to you you know my
opinion and I met people that have been
on the hit list from exponent from the
Mexican Mafia you know saying all that
you know and I can't see [ __ ] because it
doesn't pertain to me it's none of my
business and if I get involved in the
same thing will happen to me you know
I've been in same change where the
homies are fixing up hotshots to the
individual that's on my list you know
and I'm just like [ __ ] what you know and
I started feeling a little some type of
way and everything but like I said it's
better you than me
straight up you know how here if you
don't know how to survive out here this
[ __ ] eat your life you know so you know
I seen I seen I seemed like that and to
this day I don't really talk about it or
who can I talk about it with you know
saying unfortunately I came across this
and Here I am now tell you my story you
know saying for those that want to how
can I say grab it or use it for whatever
benefits you for any type of experience
or whatnot by all means but I've not
been paid shoot yourself pretty much and
learned the hard way like I did
kids of Europe I have six kids six years
I have six kids my oldest kid is 21
years old to this day he's reaching up
for me but I have nothing to offer him
so I feel I feel worthless in that
aspect where I can do nothing for him we
ever in his life I was in I was in his
life for this first three years I said
but my baby mama team attorney she
traumatize me where I see all females
the same you know I can't be nice to you
them or I can I say whine them and dine
them because once I started doing that
so [ __ ] me over you know and hold what
the next manner or the [ __ ] got
too big a sack you know I got my
daughter her 15 years old her
quinceanera is this year I don't know
what exact date but I haven't been in
her life really the past seven years due
to the fact that I've been in in and out
of prison in jail I caught my five-year
term right here selling selling crack to
an undercover cop you know this
individual
look worst of the worst he had dirty a
snake [ __ ] foul clothes he had those
bunnies on his hair and you never would
have expected he asked me for a 2000
rock I served it to him next thing you
know you see the marks swooping up and I
ran inside a liquor store area I'm
Crocker rather on colder and front of
the post office used to be a liquor
store right there right inside right
there that through all the rocks you
know all the crack keys that were in
there it was like a [ __ ] like a party
[ __ ]
so I've gotten everything right so I'm
gonna [ __ ] it you mean so anyway so the
police went in there they dragged me out
and I'm and I was a man was talking
about how no what the [ __ ] you guys
talking about next thing you know you
see that guy that undercover cop with
the dustbunnies 13a coming he had a
[ __ ] big ass round badge skirt badge
you know and I was like [ __ ] so ever
since then I learned kind of who the
subtle - or not - so dope
- had people going up to my spot where
like $200 trying to buy some heroin and
I wouldn't serve it and for the same
reason you know so I guess he's all like
I say you got to learn the hard way and
I learned the hard way
you know I got I got into so many I got
like 12 fights with the blacks out here
I got stabbed three times out here in
the street oh my gosh shot at I shop all
the [ __ ] you know I didn't know me
and I kind of earned my respect and hold
my ground down here but it's it's not
it's not really rocket science because
we're outnumbered pal [ __ ] you
know me it's like 100 blacks - one
Mexican higher you know so if you
survive out here then I mean you got how
to survive other than that you know
other than that like you know I had good
jobs I used to do termination getting 42
dollars an hour
prevailing wage I used to work for a UPS
you know to this day I still have my ups
I D badge you know just something meant
it's something mental for me you know
but um how long I guess the drug
addiction drug addiction can really get
a hold of you if you can't control it
you know and and there's been points in
my life where I can't
solely because I leave everything behind
from my kids to my baby's mama to my
good working jobs knowledge and and it's
not worth it I know it's not worth it
you know and but I don't know
ignorance and it's being stubborn they
just just cuz I know what to do I know
what's right and what's wrong and I
still choose to do the wrong things you
know knowing that I'm hurting everybody
in the pack in my life you know from
baby mama to my kids to to my parents my
brothers you know I mean that's but we
are making wrong choices you know we're
all [ __ ] adults growing in and we all
know what the [ __ ] were doing or what we
get ourselves into
so something is like when I started
feeling this way or crying or white mat
you know it's saying come on stop
feeling self pity for yourself you know
what the [ __ ] is doing and you know what
you do to get out of this [ __ ]
you know but knowing all that you still
want to be in a [ __ ] I don't know
why I understand why no I just see this
is what it is some things you know I you
feel like you you feel like you belong
here no I don't belong here
um before my self-esteem was very high
very high and um and I know what I'm so
worth you know do - I want a PCC College
you know I graduated but
pre-apprenticeship certificate you know
arm so III I done little things that
know I could be successful I lived a
successful life before I was making
$1700 from Monday to Friday working
seven hours seven and a half hours
demolition you know making that kind of
money you know and for me to lose at all
because a dope or just trying to just
being irresponsible you know it's kind
of like it eats you up inside a lot of
people don't know what people go through
emotionally and personally you know like
there's their issues or whatnot you know
I you know that's what it is you know
other type I'm the black sheep of the
family so you know I get out of jail or
whatever the case may be I land a job
and right away my parents are on my ass
all you gotta pay rent with the wool you
gotta do this you gotta pay bills
etcetera what my brother's been working
for in there they've been having
they've been stable have steady jobs
with the farmer John's UPS drivers
making [ __ ] Bank making decent money
and they live with my parents and they
never had a pay rent not one time you
know or contribute whatsoever but when I
get there it's like oh hey you need to
pay rent and I'm like man I'm gonna
[ __ ] jump I just got I do you know
and my family they showed our preference
a lot of preference that's probably why
I choose to do what I what I do you know
my parents are the type of is they're
mad at me they won't say hi to my kids
won't be
you know say so that kinda makes me feel
some supper whaling very very personal
you know I got a little [ __ ] about me
but why are you gonna neglect your
grandchildren because I mean you know a
grandparent will look more lovely Greg
well other grandkids regardless right I
know oh yeah but so I try to tough it
out I totally suck it up I try to be
[ __ ] mr. macho and mr. tough guy not
actually you know but the apparently
seriously like you people only really
know what the [ __ ] am I posed to do you
know like but if you show these kind of
emotions out there then you're a
straight [ __ ] or you're a weak or
mother [ __ ] whoa whoa [ __ ] prayer
on you you know and [ __ ] that [ __ ] like
you know I mean I don't look like I
don't know like I'm a weakness poker you
know I'm all tatted up and all that [ __ ]
I've been in prison I've been right I
stabbed all the [ __ ] is in jail in a
shoe program I don't know that [ __ ] you
know I've been a three-yard and
everything you know and I promoted in
2000 and 2009 I just showed my number
2010 and I haven't been in the prison
ever since but I've been in out of
county jail everything you know all
these years and every time I go to jail
or whatever I get a little spot or in a
play in position you know and I run
dorms I run [ __ ] or whatever because I
know certain certain individuals you
know but like if more [ __ ] really
know like how much all [ __ ]
[ __ ] is really because I love I
love I love to I like to love you know
sobriety is good be normal is good
that's just fun you know like well
you're out here just with your life this
[ __ ] eat you up alive and it damages
everybody I Roger you know not even you
know just the people that do care about
you or love you like they're the ones
that go through it you for me like
but um your kids take the hit hardest
yeah you know because I right now just
the kid you know he's not just think
he's eight years old and I know that
what he's missing and he's missing me
you know but you know like eyelid eyelid
little arguments or or stupid [ __ ] just
to Gore me you know and then right away
I try to fight it and escape or you know
like oh I gotta go relapse because of
this and once I relapse I don't give a
[ __ ] about nothing I don't give a [ __ ]
about [ __ ] you know I do what I gotta do
and that's it and then I'm out here
rolling around like like just waiting to
get killed or something and and and I
read on you know I don't know [ __ ] about
[ __ ] you know my emotions die you know I
could care less if my mom was diner in
her hospital bed and if I'm under the
influence I gonna care and that's and I
know that's wrong that's all bad you
know on Christmas I seen my same I seen
my son my 21 year old son last two years
of I seen them I said I'm a Christmas is
the first time I seen him in ten years
right
whoa iin dedup doing an issue before
that and I went to go see him and when I
got there my dad was like oh hey your
son's here so I cried would the war like
dig I told him to come down here you
know to me this time cuz he didn't have
a family
his mom was the [ __ ] drug addict as
well and she used to kick him when he
will be color in his books
she'll go in the house and just kick him
out of nowhere you know I think he was
telling me all these things you know and
um so when I went to my mom's house he
shows up or whatever we started
socializing etc and he's like a dad you
know like you're like you don't want a
guy here my brothers my hand my you know
they showed emotion they started crying
though I their eyes got watery
etc right so it will have come you
didn't get emotional when you saw me or
whatnot you know and that's what I'm
straight out you're not a little you're
21 years old oh my god I think it's all
their lives or already but the reason
I'm so emotional because I'm under the
influence you know and
the house [ __ ] up but I thought that
was [ __ ] up for him I didn't take a
picture with him no nothing
you know the night came to an end and my
brother took him home and he was like
all right so I'll see you later and I
will aaaa whatever you know because why
because my mind was somewhere else you
know and that's that you know I might
not be keen I've been clean going like a
little bit over two weeks you know but
it goes to a point where I can't even
became for like not even 30 minutes you
know and but you know right now I'm
really I want to stay clean I'm going to
do I'm going to be soaked like trying to
be sober as to my full capacity you know
other than that that's a story of my
life hey thank you very much
you